what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to frito
bang's
new song um jail blues which is
ironic i don't want to say ironic but
that's not the right words but i
word but i think he's in jail right now
but i'm also not sure
because on his instagram story
he was like talking about how he's going
to release this music
but i don't think you can do that in
jail
i don't know i'm gonna react to it
[Music]
though
i'm so tired of seeing these grey walls
i know my mama ate the phone calls
and they say i won't see the judge the
monday
[Music]
surroundings gotta stay up on my tent i
know this [ __ ] from that world and i
could feel it in the wind
i think that he got some beef with my
king
[ __ ] [ __ ] we could get in
prosecutors wanna
[Music]
okay so he's just basically talking
about how he wants to get out of jail
um i actually like this song i think
it's it's like very touching like it
makes my heart
like a little bit of empathy i guess and
is a heater a gun because he said he got
caught with a heater and i'm pretty sure
the reason he's in jail is because of a
[Music]
gun
[Music]
so the one thing that's interesting to
me about like rap and watching rap is
like
all this stuff a lot not always but
sometimes the stuff that they talk about
is actually going on and happening
so it's interesting because it's almost
like reality tv
in a way like watching these rappers
make music about different stuff that
they're actually going through because
it's stuff that's actually like
happening and that makes people want to
watch the music
more because they want to know what's
going on in their life almost not my job
i swatches
i hope they think about me there we go
got a heart in this [ __ ]
ain't got too many options i'm sick of
eating cold meals and taking cold
[Music]
showers
[Music]
i got
i'm really confused if he's in jail how
how he
recorded this
[Music]
violet i really appreciate the music
that he had
in the background for this song
um i'm gonna give this i really liked
that song actually i'm gonna give it a
five
five out of five i think that the lyrics
were
like very well written like i can tell
what's going on and i think it's easy to
understand
um i really appreciate when they have
like other instruments in the background
the piano i mean he had the little
guitar strumming
and yeah so that's why i'd actually give
that a five out of five but let me know
what you guys think in the comments
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification
bell and i will talk to you guys next